this is ping  a southern three-banded armadillo  predators look elsewhere you'll have a  hard time cracking open this critter  like all armadillos they are covered by  bony plates that make up their shell  but the southern three-banded armadillo  is the only armadillo species that can  roll themselves into a near-perfect bowl  when threatened  these little guys are native to central  south america and prefer dry vegetation  there they feed off insects that they  dig up with their sharp powerful claws  and gather with long sticky straw-like  tongue  but even body armor can't protect this  species from numerous human made threats  on top of a dwindling habitat they are  hunted heavily for food and the pet  trade  this is the southern three-banded  armadillo  you